hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
another key assumption or if you like
explicit doctrine of st. Anselm's
metaphysical perspective then it plays a
very important role in the Mona loggia
and in other works is what we can call
the doctrine of degrees of being here
this is an important plainest or
neoplatonist doctrine you're gonna find
it not only in your christian plainness
such as handsome and its predecessors
like Boethius or say you know augustine
you're also going to find it in other
plateless philosophers including those
who are you know pagans like Latinas and
his students you're gonna find this in
amel platonism in general this idea that
there are degrees or levels of being not
just you know my you might say more and
less in the sense of having more or less
equality but more and less in terms of
actual being this is an idea that has
been largely rejected although sometimes
it could smuggle back in in different
ways in modern thought and so it's worth
dwelling on it a bit
as you're approaching an Psalms text not
so that you necessarily become convinced
that that's not the goal in trying to
make sense of it but so that you can
understand the an Psalms perspective
more adequately and see how its
argumentation is supposed to work you
know it's one thing to say I reject him
altogether and that's all of nonsense
it's another to say well I find this
assumption questionable but I do see how
what he's saying would follow if you
grant that assumption and so that's
something that's open to you if you do
indeed understand the doctrine now like
it would here one way to understand this
is the assertion that there are
fundamentally different basic types of
beings that are on different levels
ontological or metaphysically they have
more or less being and and someone else
will talk about them as having greater
or lesser dignity so this is worth
dwelling on for a moment what do we mean
by having more or less being you might
say I have no clue about what that's
supposed to translate into having more
or less being is literally what it what
it's saying that there are some beings
that don't really exist in the same way
or to the same degree as higher beings
who actually have greater existence and
then there might be levels higher and
higher there's there's sort of a
fullness you can think about this in
terms of you know parts and wholes if
you like it's not necessarily saying
that like Society has greater existence
than human beings the Anselm is not
committed to anything like that but we
do often want to reduce thanks to their
basic components and say well the basic
components are what's most real and you
put them together certain ways and then
somehow you get life right or you put
living things together in certain ways
and suddenly you get sentience and yeah
those are just sort of you know Envy
phenomena where supervening things
whatever you want six the plateless
viewpoint instead of saying we begin
from building on the bottom and then go
up begins at the top and goes downward
and says as we get further and further
away from the top we're dealing with
things that really exist less they they
don't have the same degree or the same
intensity you might say of being as
higher levels do so a very fascinating
way of looking at things if you do look
at things in that way there's a kind of
a sort of unfolding or reversal that
takes place in your perspective no
there's two places in the Mona loggia
where in some very explicitly invokes
this doctrine one is in chapter 4 where
he's using one kind of example and then
there is chapter 31 where he uses
another kind of example 31 is a little
bit more developed so we'll look at that
one second but there's some interesting
structural features that are the same in
both cases some of it you can see from
looking at the board right now I think
the correlation human being is rational
being right horse is perceptive being
would if it was living it was living
being now it's probably just you know a
block of wood that's actually dead right
bear being but there's more to the story
than just that and I'll show you as we
go through
so let's actually look at what aunts
home says I think this is very important
it's funny passage to so he says is that
the very beginning of chapter 4 if
someone considers the nature's of things
the way things are right he cannot help
realizing they are not of all equal
dignity rather some of them are on
different and on equal levels ok that's
what we talked about here for anyone who
doubts that a horse is by its very
nature better than wood and that a human
being is more excellent than a horse
should not even be called a human being
that's an interesting thing to say for
several
we're talking about the natures of
things as those kinds of things a horse
as a horse as a living thing a horse is
better than a block of what a human
being is better than a horse notice that
that saying a horse has some value a
horse as a living thing has a relative
value that is greater than that of just
a block of wood or even you know hole
maybe the forest of wood but it's not as
much as a human being one human being
might be said to outweigh a whole bunch
of horses
quaaack Yuman being right and and so
this implies that other measures that we
use might not be getting at the reality
of things but but just be dependent on
others now why does he say that that
somebody who doesn't realize this he
says somebody who doesn't grasp that a
horse is by its very nature better than
wood but a human being is more excellent
than a horse should not be called a
human being why not well because a human
being is rational that is what makes the
human being better than the horse so a
human being who can't realize that is in
a certain way lacking in what is of the
very nature of human beings namely to be
better than horses what makes us better
than horses the very fact that we can
realize not just in a sort of value
response way or emotionally but
intellectually that we are in fact
better than horses the horse I suppose
knows it's better than the hay that it
eats because it just ain't right it
doesn't have to think about it it does
it more or less instinctually but
there's this this this very important
aspect here where Ansel is going to say
this level all of this is brought into
perspective
so that doesn't happen at these lower
levels the horse doesn't worry about
whether the human being is better than
it or whether it's better than the human
being it just horses around it does
horsey stuff because that's its nature
the human being the human rational being
is able to grasp that and so to fail to
do that is in a certain sense to not
necessarily lose one's humanity but so
you might say short circuit to put it in
suspension he says since some nature's
are better than others reason makes it
no less obvious that one of them is so
preeminent that's where this is actually
going now in chapter 31 we have a much
longer discussion and this one is in
terms of the word and you know beings
correspondence with the word a whole
different topic that I don't want to get
mired down in too much at this point but
he goes on they says that every
intellect judges that nature's that are
in some way living are it more excellent
than those that are not right so there's
a difference in quality their natures
that perceive those that do not pursue
right rational natures than that which
lacks reason so there's a difference in
quality the difference in we might say
dignity or goodness is it a difference
in being he goes on and he says yes
indeed he says that there we go when
we're talking about the supreme nature
the supreme nature not really exists the
littles and Perseus and was rational of
all the existing things what is in some
way living is more like the supreme
being like being itself then what is it
no way living what in some way knows
something even through a bodily sense is
more like him than what precedes nothing
at all what is rational is more like him
than what is
not capable of reasoning Lenny says by a
similar argument it's clear that certain
nature's exist more greatly or to a
lesser degree than others so the higher
we go on it it's not just a difference
in quality it's also a difference in da
ting itself greater being at these
levels notice that each of these levels
incorporates the previous level before
it so that nonliving being is not
something that isn't there in living
being living being just happens to
transform nonliving being into living
being perceptive being is living being
that is also perceptive and is thereby
more being than just merely living like
an oyster for example I have oysters
perceiving all that you get the idea
rational being presumably is a greater
degree of being according to an some the
critics of many other people then merely
perceptive animal being yes so we've got
this very interesting things up let me
go so how many does a thought experiment
he says imagine that we have a substance
that lives in as capable of perception
and his reaction so it's at the highest
level right now we start taking things
away we take away its rationality then
its ability to perceive then its life
and finally the beer being a bare
existence
nuta messing in in latin of his text
noonim naked SN being and what do we
have there he says the substance is
destroyed a little at a time that it's
gradually brought to exist less and less
and finally now to exist at all so below
this we have nothing
it's nothingness and nothing this isn't
really anything right
it's just non-being if we go higher up
we find more and more being in rational
being like human beings are not actually
at the top of the scale what's at the
top of the scale is
cream being which incorporates all of
this but also in certain important
respects goes beyond it as well we don't
need to necessarily worry about that I
just want to signal to you that this is
not the very top low what do we have
that similar to these well like I said
we can map these on to each other right
but you notice that this function of
rationality he says every intellect
every rational being he's not using
intellect as something different than
reason in this case he is able to take
into account its difference to these
others things that is again at the core
of what it means to be human or if you
like because it's not just humans and
irrational of hansoms metaphysical
scheme to be rational be it to grasp the
differences in this to be able to
understand that there are degrees of
being so that is a very important
doctrine to keep in mind as you're
approaching an psalms monologue m and
hopefully that clears it up a bit for
you